although you know hosts are promoted on
tv
you know i'm under the impression that
almost on like a national level it's
something that they try and keep kind of
hidden and that that like they they're
not too proud of
would you would you say i guess that's
the whole reason why we got yes
open your eyes so like over the past 10
years would you say that hosts and host
clubs become less popular or more
popular
really massively why would you say that
again thanks to roland kind of people
who yeah
mainstream and showcase that becoming a
whole is it just rolling though or is it
maybe because the whole subculture of
host clubs have just become a little bit
more open to like a general public maybe
yeah it's becoming like but that what
helped to achieve what you just talked
about is through manga anime
right a lot of these media's picked up
on that and they're glorified right yeah
they make it look yeah it's actually fun
or in high school
like or in high school yeah it couldn't
be further from that yeah
you guys know this anime where like this
guy who does whatever the [ __ ] he wants
in school and everybody's like
mesmerized by him
with that information
crazy tell you anything you know yeah
yeah
i love soccer
exactly that you know what where does
that drive from the core of that
principle comes from the hostile
mentality of being this you know
superior untouchable [ __ ] you know
mighty being in the japanese meanwhile
they're throwing up in the match
yeah yeah after they've had a few one
too many tricks so i mean to pick your
points
doesn't show you
sakamoto injecting steroids
the core roots of the thing you know is
the same yeah that's right
yeah
it's interesting because it's just so
[ __ ]
yeah
it's like you're literally in life yeah
but it's like it's just kind of crazy to
think that there are people who
literally put their life on the line to
like maintain a facade because
you know that's what gets them the money
right yeah yeah yeah i mean it's not the
only japanese industry that does that
right you look at the [ __ ] idol
industry oh yeah it's it's entirely
based on
like maintaining an image and dude i'd
say that's ten times more toxic bro
yeah yeah coming from
from i mean
it says it says it says a lot it says a
lot with the host says that after
everything you said i said today
absolutely horror story which is why i'm
like i don't even think you're wrong in
saying that after the stories i thought
my psychology comes from this and i
think this also relates to you know
other idol related industries that are
still popping up to this day which is
educating your audience
right your audience is your main sort of
income right at the end of the day
and
within the idle industry they're so
strict about everything that the you
know females do the relationship they
have with the boys or like any kind of
interactions they have
it's almost toxic
yeah but why does that even exist
that's because the industry standard is
bred to be that way yeah yeah
so you have to educate your own audience
so that you're more free you're more
open you're more willing to accept you
know radical ideas into your business
like no one's no one's willing to take
that risk yeah are they well the
companies aren't no no no the companies
are well like asian dudes in suits bro
like
how are you gonna teach them new tricks
man
you're not gonna i get what you're
saying you just couldn't have said it in
the worst way possible you know like
i guess you're you're asian right it's
okay
i'm brutal in the way i carry myself
forward well i guess you have to be to
survive as a host right at times like
generally as a businessman too bro my
current job is mostly about convincing
people to do [ __ ] that i want them to
right
why make it sound so sinister
[ __ ] this is one thing i promised myself
not to do to seem like a sinister
[ __ ] malicious bastard
well i mean like
the thing is like i get what you're
saying right because especially when it
comes to the idle industry where it's
like you know industries don't want to
take a stab at like a new idea because
again it goes back to that whole thing
of like maintaining tradition right
maintaining this is how we've been doing
it it's been working so far let's do it
idols can't [ __ ] say anything because
the moment they're like um i have a
radical idea and they're like all right
bye-bye bye-bye
say bye to your career say goodbye and
then if a fan says uh hey maybe this is
kind of [ __ ] up then the community
gets on his ass and goes like ah get the
[ __ ] out then right so it's like no one
wins there's no space for change until
yeah as you said like at the end of the
day you need to get like the entirety to
be like oh yeah this [ __ ] maybe we
should change it and that changes over
time you know though that can't be
something that's done overnight but like
at the same time
who's going to take that first step
right because it's that's a massive risk
and i'm ten years of the business bro
in whatever format that is whether it's
you know reality
they want to risk everything that
they've built up over time for just like
they're not gonna do that right that's
that's the issue that is that is
unfortunately the issue unless you have
someone like super smart like again like
roland right like i guess he's the
greatest it takes a [ __ ] person like
roland to really shake things up yeah
the example i want to give here is from
naruto
[Laughter]
you're serious
if you can if you if you
if you say believe it i will actually
smack you wait
you did not just dead ass look me in the
face and say that chat no
don't lose hope on me here bro yeah okay
so explain yourself
you guys know itachi right
after all this time [ __ ] you
i haven't watched naruto what you guys
know i haven't watched an outro no we
don't how did you pop off on youtube
by not watching
what did you do
you know what i do you give me hope bro
why me you give me hope that in five
years maybe i can be like
why do you want to be like me well no
you can't because you've seen naruto no
shh yeah so you have no chance of life
yeah okay you should go on tell us about
you then
well tell us about it there's no
interest
yeah he's not going to kill him you need
to worry about he's not going to care
can you guys refresh me on what the main
topic is
you were about to give some life advice
concerning itachi yeah i'm naruto why
though
pioneer or something you are quite drunk
you finished you finished it
guys please be sure unless i get to this
point
okay soul breast daily tell us the story
so basically you know hitachi
sacrificed his whole life being for the
greater good that he believed in
i sure he had to fill in at a age that
you know even he had no understanding or
conscious about okay stop laughing [ __ ]
go on go on go on just
stop laughing [ __ ]
it's so hard to sound smart when you
talk
that's why we leave that's why we're
historical figures who sacrificed their
entire existence for a cause and out of
all of them you chose [ __ ] touching
naruto but
he's very well suited though oh yeah
okay i'll go on then go on make your
point
so he was terrifying was there a place
he sacrifices him himself for the
greater good of the family
you are the one who was like bro itachi
itachi though
pioneer we were talking about pioneers
who shake up the [ __ ] industry he
sacrificed everything and then you said
itachi sacrificed his entire life
exactly so for example in the verse
right if hitachi didn't do what he did
nobody would have come to realization of
you know the whole
like the dilemma of following the past
and continuing the path you do leading
to the same outcome continuing the
lineage right yeah exactly because you
know the whole sasuke people and the
naruto people sorry
i just have this you're talking about
the uchiha class
the woman's sitting down in the football
stadium the guys in the ear
with the host club
sacrificed his life he's like for the
greater good he's talking about how he
[ __ ] was like you need life
experience he's like so naruto right
bro you won't believe it
so so when he had the sand thing he
broke he hit it he took off the weights
it was insane bro he took them off and
he just should have been there
it changed history
okay
is this what you'll be telling the girls
just talk my narrative oh no
that's different okay so so so
you were saying so he sacrifices himself
for the good of the uchiha family
exactly and right greater good not even
finally
he knew the clan yeah yeah
i i like sasuke people you know
people yeah
yeah
i'm sorry
i'm so sorry he totally loves naruto
yeah i do though i wanted to i [ __ ]
read the manga did you you didn't [ __ ]
you so you know that that's what i
consider the you know like
the core medium ass manga if you haven't
read the manga and you just watch them
anime
you want you ain't true [ __ ] fan
okay in my book so you know to those
people who watch berserk anime you don't
read the manga and you consider yourself
a fan
you better don't i mean
what happened to the life advice
the life advice here is that so if
itachi didn't take the path he did we
would have never reached the conclusion
that you know like chuas
yeah coming together to understand each
other will be a solution i know it's
such a cheesy [ __ ] and you know naruto
gives you that but
at the end of the day that's what it
came down to right it's actually going
to break that path right all right let's
listen to the companies
so what you're saying is every industry
needs an itachi exactly
exactly you might sacrifice yourself
your own being your own career but it's
for the greater good of reaching uh you
know
a beautiful speech thanks thanks for
coming is ted talk uh itachi yeah you
buy him a drink now you have to buy me a
drink now we'll have to buy you a drink
now for that life advice no no no not a
champagne towel not a champagne towel oh
buy you a normal drink at a normal bar
i'm waiting for you guys at my next
birthday
would you okay okay hypothetically right
will be kicked out yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh my god
you can't get in so unfortunately it's
only joey joey
[ __ ]
hypothetically though would you even
would you even accept if i if i did
actually buy you a champagne towel [ __ ]
you bro okay
you know i thought you were going to be
like a bro and be like no no no your
mother
because that happens a lot actually what
what what
the homies inviting their other homies
to bruce jewell numbers and not just
boost your numbers but to drink with you
because as i said a lot of the most
successful this woman was born as [ __ ]
bro
yeah that's the case because as i said
most successful hosts they're so busy in
the evening that like even if you're
good homies you don't get to drink with
that guy right so sometimes you're like
bro
i want to i want to drink with you
you know i'm with your club and you're
like yeah sure bro just pay the price
and come over this is like mid maxing
me maxing social interest i get to hang
out with my bros and i get paid yeah
exactly but mean you usually what you do
is the money they pay you that gets into
your pocket you kind of give it back to
them in the next drinking
oh yeah yeah all right you pay for them
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you can't be a total social [ __ ] so
what you're saying is if i bought you a
dom perignon champagne tower for your
birthday you will happily say hell yeah
but then you'd buy me drinks
bro see me paying you back for the rest
of [ __ ] time
i don't even want to know how much that
is yeah right they probably go for like
like more than 10k right like 10 how
many six digits 100k
some places we're talking jpy or dollars
dollars
six digits yeah it's not like six it's
like martin kind of [ __ ] bro like so it
exists it does oh my god
could you imagine spending a hundred
thousand dollars on a dude for his
birthday
no i can't even imagine spending a
hundred thousand dollars yeah right
other than like a house that you're
investing in or something imagine you're
the daughter of a billionaire right yeah
then what are you gonna do your life is
all about
spending money waiting to marry the
right guy yeah well that's that's a
totally different world yeah that's
we're not we're not the daughter of a
billionaire you know i know i know but
i'm just giving you a perspective yeah
another life maybe another life yeah or
the life indeed